2005 gunit tour 50 was touring so I get
on the bus and we roll out to Vegas yep
the bus driver is like there will be no
cigarette smoking on the bus and so I
opened up a window and I'm like hanging
out of the window smoking a cigarette
out the back of the bus and the bus
driver is losing his mind he's so pissed
he's like I said no smoking on the bus
and I said I was halfway out the window
and the bus driver says you think I need
a white boy hanging out my window on a
rap
tour before we get to Vegas I'm passed
out on the floor of the bus I heard you
had a big bottle of mustard you
squeezing it in mouth sque it in your
mouth
bro you filled my mouth with mustard I'm
sleeping and in my sleep I like go and I
like throw the horns and swallow and
swallow the mustard bro I was like oh
yeah this mother right here is just too
crazy bro